ce petit ruban rouge que j'ai mis le
temps de ce reportage a un sens c'est un
très beau symbole tous contre le sida ce
petit ruban vous allez le voir à nouveau
sur toutes les chaînes de télévision sur
six chaînes de télévision dont bien sûr
france 2 le 7 avril prochain et le
symbole sera très fort et très beau les
six chaînes de télévision ont décidé de
diffuser ce soir là le 7 avril la même
émission le même programme contre le
sida
philippe gassot et françois gagnon tu as
assisté ce matin à la présentation du
programme à la boutonnière la légion
d'honneur de la solidarité contre la
sida la télé ou plutôt toutes les télés
ont pris leur élan pour tenter de
franchir l'obstacle de la maladie même
si pour cela pour une fois le remède est
contre nature
ce sera la réserve et l'humilité qui
prévaudrait sur les écrans c'est une
histoire fabuleuse pour faire progresser
la lutte contre le sida
les journalistes ne s'y sont pas trompés
le rendez vous n'a pas été manqué car il
s'agit là d'une première mondiale du
jamais vu une mobilisation générale
un début la solution ne vient pas de la
télé elle viendra les chercheurs elle
viendra d'un scientifique
elle viendra des médecins mais pour ce
qui nous concerne nous avons fait et
nous ferons sharks kg
notre devoir c'est pierre elkabbach et
grands rendez-vous va servir à complexe
la prévention à lui donner aux
chercheurs en plus des fonds publics
les moyens de leur recherche en france
et ailleurs
et en même temps démontrer la solidarité
à l'égard de ceux qui sont atteints de
la maladie et leur donner peut-être une
part d'espérance oublier pour un temps
les télés bataille de tranchées le côté
mon l'audimat et puis groupe nokia
la cause est commune mais surtout pas
ordinaire la guerre des chaînes quelle
guerre je vais essayer de résumer ça
avec athlètes mois plus tôt est-ce idea
solidarité informations découvertes
amour moi je suis sûr que c'est ce genre
d'opération cette mobilisation générale
qui va tout changer tout va changer de
main dites le autour de vous vous rendez
vous le 7 avril devant la télé tous
contre le sida